There are three different logistic
regression algorithms that
are typically used.
The one we just looked
at is the default, and
it is called the logit
transformation equation.
That is what we're going to
focus on in our analysis, but
let me briefly explain
the other two options.
The second option is the probit
transformation equation.
It looks very similar to
the logit formula and
actually gives a very similar result.
The third section and the last option
is the log-log transformation.
This is the best option for
you if you think the percent
change in the predictor variables
will represent the percent
change in the target variable.
But like I said, we're not going to
focus on these last two algorithms and
rather just focus on the logit
logistic regression.
For these and the other models
taught throughout the course,
we're going to stay away from the math.
And instead we'll focus on what the
algorithms are doing conceptually, how
to apply them, and how we can interpret
them inside the Alteryx platform.
We'll be using Alteryx, because most
of the models are outside of what
typical tools like
Excel can actually do.